Hey,
what's going on in bill burn?
It's time for the Monday morning
podcast for Monday, September 4th,
2017 how's it going? How? Why
you? Happy fucking Labor Day.
Happy Labor Day.
You don't have to go to
fucking work unless you're
the guy that owns the fucking
business. Stan, you never get to sleep.
[inaudible] you showed a
stuck with your first wife,
but you threw her out and now you got a
fucking 20 something fucking cop and she
wants to spend all your money. All right,
sorry. Anyways. Oh, you know something.
You worked hard all year.
God dammit.
It's nice that you got a
fucking a Monday off, isn't it?
Don't you wish it was
the way it is in Europe?
I don't know how they do it over there.
You know they all got
fucking health insurance.
They get like 53 weeks off a year.
Then I'd like the,
the whole fucking continence shuts down
in August. Everybody just says fuck it.
We're not working and
somehow it keeps going.
Is it because their countries is so
small doll? Look at the little country,
is that what it is
over here is so fucking big.
You know, just a mow. Your yard takes
half the God damn summer over here.
All of us fat fucks.
Walnut hill and around a giant pieces
of property Rad and a four wheeler
shooting their guns. You fucking
live over there in, in Europe man.
You get, you got nothing. You got a flat,
you know,
you and five other guys
fucking addicted to heroin.
When some baby drowns in a toilet or
whatever they're fucking movie was,
you know you got nothing on.
Maybe.
Maybe you got a house and
it's got like the fucking,
it's got that roof that looks like a
bale of hay that someone braided in.
It looks like a weave but with like,
hey, I don't know what it is over there,
but all I know is they still have castles.
Some of them still have kings
and queens and they, they get,
they get like August off,
cyst off.
You know when they get free healthcare,
they pay a bunch of fucking taxes.
But I gotta be honest,
you pay a bunch of taxes here too.
I think it's just cause we're bigger.
Got The wide open fucking roads.
I'm going to go with that.
I'm going to go with that and
I'm never gonna read up about it.
And that's what I'm going to say.
If that topics ever brought up like hey,
I've come uh,
come,
they get all this vacation time and
if a woman has a kid over there raw,
she doesn't have to be back to work
on Monday, I'll come that it's,
oh cause they're little tiny countries,
you know, they have little tiny hospitals,
you know, a little tiny teeth that
they don't brush. You know, it's, it's,
it's Europe. What do
you, anybody, even though
it's where the cars go
better in the corners,
they have little tiny
streets and they're gonna,
they're gonna zig zag around some shit.
You know that,
that's basically what it is.
It's not like America.
It's a woman gives birth on Friday and
then the eight gene makes sure you're
fucking here on Monday,
pumped dad kit
out,
do whatever it is you got to do.
Yeah. Have you gotten to stick
a weed whacker? Other hour,
fucking reverse blower up down.
Suck the kid out and be back to work.
We'll give you Monday off.
Then you've got to be here on Tuesday.
That's how it works here in America.
Everybody wonders why was so fat has
nothing to do with our poison food.
We're just stressed.
You know,
if you guys didn't have a whole month
of August off over there in Europe,
I'd love to see if you guys actually
had to fucking work over there and worry
about, you know, I need a new pancreas.
How am I going to afford that?
Right. Which is easily the cost
of at least three flat screen TVs.
That's the going rate for a pancreas,
if I remember correctly. All right.
If you were dealing with that stress,
I'd like to see how many fucking
donuts you'd be. You know, uh,
speaking of which, uh,
Billy, no fun. Billy.
No Fun is on his 18th day of not boozing,
18 days, not booze. And I
barely even remember what it
tastes like at this point.
You know, I'm dropping weight. This
is the time of night when it sucks.
Um, you know, in the morning
it's great. I wake up,
my stomach's flatter than it
was the day before. I felt good,
but it's like at night, I
mean, it's Sunday night.
I don't have to go to work on Monday.
I have tomorrow off like all of you
guys while you listen to to it today,
you know, you can't tell me, you know,
I mean as,
as a fucking human being and I have to
go out and get fucking hammered. Right.
I mean, what kind of, I mean,
I, if I don't, I mean, if I
was running the CIA, I'd be,
you know, there's this guy in Isis
see some sort of religious fanatic.
MMM.
Oh, Billy red cakes. Oh, Billy red velvet.
I'm staying away from the sugar.
I'm being an angel of being an angel
because I might have some active work in,
um, in October. So a,
I gotta make sure I'm down to my
fighting weight of my fighting weight.
A buck 72. That's what I need to
be at. Whenever I shoot something,
you know all these fucking actresses
out here and talk about how it's so hard
for them is if a guy can
go on and be a bloated fat,
fucking not get shit for it.
Okay
it,
that's not how it works.
They can get to you through social media.
They go right at you and they tell you
that you're a bloated fed fuck what
happened to you. You got old,
which a hair go, all of that shit.
You know what I mean? But you know,
you know what it is about people.
They look out their own fucking heads,
all right,
and they look at the world
in a two dimensional way.
They look out their heads,
they observe something and then they put
it their head and they process it with
their previous experience and
then to them that is the truth.
That is what's going on in the world.
They look at it from their fucking angle
and they don't realize it that it's 360
degrees,
which is why South Park is the greatest
fucking show of all time as far as I'm
concerned, because no matter what problem
they attack, they hit it from all sides.
The red side, the blue side from
the north, south, east, west.
You know what I'm saying?
You liked that. That was,
that was the longest
fucking compliment ever. Ah,
Josh Adam Meyers from
the goddamn comedy jam.
Josh Adam Meyers, Bill Burr. I'm
taping my Monday morning podcast.
You're one of our first caller's.
How are you?
I'm just curious.
I wasn't aware that that happened.
Was that a big news story
in the world of sports?
Do people know about it?
Uh, you know, as a, as a fucking lover
of the Celtics, as this Celtics lover,
I hated the fucking trade because I loved
Isaiah. He was like a mini big PAPI.
He was on his way. He was going to
have a street named after him. But, uh,
that it's, it's a business.
Now when this all goes back,
I think to the Miami Heat,
all those pylon teams back to the Cobi
Shaq Lakers when whenever it stopped
being bird bird, Celtics,
magic Lakers, Isaiah fucking,
uh, the Pistons, Jordan with the bowls
and everybody just jumped around.
Now it's over. I thought you
were gonna ask about the cigar.
I am.
That's what I was saying.
No,
I don't give a shit.
Just ring the doorbell and I'll
stop and I'll finish it later.
All right,
closing a little bit.
Oh, it don't hate, don't ring
the doorbell. My daughter's
sleeping. Just text me.
I'd see. Um, anyways,
the most roundabout compliment ever.
Okay.
For South Park. I had no idea I was
going to say that. So, uh, I am,
as of this morning, I have 179
pounds, six ounces once 79.6.
So I'm trying to lose three weeks or
next week on Friday, I need to be a,
I need to be one 77.
I just had to hit pause. I'm
in the fucking dog house. I
just woke up my daughter.
Oh my God, my wife is fucking
pissed at me. Boy. Boy,
you brother.
All right.
This is the Monday morning podcast and
I'm going to be fucking whisper and for
the rest of this goddamn thing,
um, that was, I talked to my, yes.
So next week I want to be 177 pounds by
a Friday and then once 74 the next week
and then I'll be one 71 and
then if I get this acting Gig,
I'll be where I need to be.
Um,
so I was going to take a month off from
boosting, but if I get this acting Gig,
then I'm just not going to booze like
right on through to the end of the fucking
shoot. And then when
that's over, okay. Uh,
I'm going to get like one of those
Kegger raters and I'm going to fill it up
with fucking whiskey
and I'm going to be underneath it
and it's going to be glorious. Um,
I dunno,
I dunno what my fucking problem is.
I should go to a meeting and
just see what that's like.
Okay.
I went to a meeting a long time ago when
I got arrested for drinking and driving
and one of the requirements was you had
to go to a in Aa meeting two of them or
something like that.
Um,
all I remember, I was just like,
these guys are fucking drunks.
I mean I drink, I don't,
I don't fucking drink.
These guys had like lunacy stories
talking about like fucking bleeding out
their acids going right to the liquor
store the next day. You know what I
mean? Like not eating food for a Mike.
Just crazy,
crazy,
crazy fucking stories.
So I just was sitting there go higher.
I'm just a drunk.
These people got a fucking problem.
I'm telling you right now, if you
ever just want to see, you know,
some of the most fucked up people on
the planet, just go to an AA meeting.
These fucking people, man. You know,
if fingers are like stuck together
from like cigarette smoke,
you know what I mean? They got
like, it just, I mean I can be,
I'm just being an asshole. I have no
idea what a fucking Aa meetings like
Anna Louise, like you get like a, a
little trinket. If you'd do it for awhile,
you know, get six days, you know,
she's Sha Faggin,
you know,
he know addictive people there.
They're fucking day.
They can never stop talking
about themselves. Right.
So think it's got to go up there. Oh Mike,
I'm going to get so much shit for this.
I don't give a fuck. I think it's about
time. Somebody fucking put a in its place,
right?
Once you grow up in white
knuckle it like the rest of us,
you got to go join a fucking group.
Everybody sits down and fucking
makes an Afghan together. Um,
you know, it's funny that I actually
would love to be part of a group.
Okay,
well my golf and up died this past week,
you know?
Yeah.
And I went with a buddy of mine and he
was like a member of a country club.
I'm like, this is fucking cool.
It's really cool. You know,
bunch of guys you could fucking talk shit,
having a great time.
All that shit that everybody fucking
gives you a rough time for, you know,
they always make fun of guys hanging out.
Now if they all hang out
together like they did,
they asked to be like mocked for
some fucking reason. It's fun.
You just sit around
breaking each other's balls.
Yeah.
That's all it was.
I went there and it was,
everybody was fucking cool and everybody
was just busting chops the whole
fucking time.
And then you go out and
golf and everybody's just
giving each other shit and
you're laughing and you smoking cigars
and you're gambling and shit. It's,
it's fun for whatever fucking reason.
I don't know if he, if you do that now,
I dunno for some reason that
that's attacked, you know,
I don't, I don't know what
the, I don't know what it is.
I don't know what the fuck
is you supposed to be doing,
but I can tell you I did enjoy it.
Um, and speaking of enjoying shit,
I know I'm all over the map.
MMM.
I felt I got caught up with
uh, the last, you know,
today's Formula One race and
uh, the previous one, like
a week ago, two weeks ago,
I missed it and I have to tell you,
I loved the force India team before I
watched the previous race and now I will
fucking love that team forever.
I will love that fucking team forever.
It at the very least,
Esteban Oh Khan in Sergio Perez,
everybody else was fucking,
was racing to not lose, you
know, didn't want to fuck up.
These fucker guys went in there.
You don't want,
I mean you ever watch a hockey fight and,
and the guys is so good at it.
They barely even punch each other.
The best ones is where you just,
you grabbed my shoulder,
I grabbed your shoulder.
We just fucking beat the shit
out of each other. You know,
that's what these guys did. They went
old time hockey with like racing.
They're on the same team.
They slammed into each other twice.
They don't even give a
fuck that it's a teammate.
This was like some sort of blood sport
that they were doing and everybody else
is out there like, oh my God,
that's my teammate. I need to,
I'm really literally making fun of the
other teams for actually doing the smart
thing.
I loved that they did it.
I loved last year when Hamilton
and a fucking a Nicki Minaj,
whatever his fucking name was,
I can remember this fucking name.
What the Hell's guy's name?
Okay,
Nikki, I want it now. I'm
taking my toys and going home.
I'm getting married now.
Rosberg right Nico Rosberg that's what
it was when they slammed into each other.
They did that a couple of
times. I liked it. And He,
and I love how these fucking drivers,
there's all of this shit where they
don't like each other. This, you know,
like Sebastian Vettel
doesn't like Lewis Hamilton.
Kimi Raikkonen doesn't
like Valtteri Botox. It's,
it's literally his fucking days
of thunder. It's tremendous.
And a, this past week's
race was great. Uh,
yesterday as far as watching
a plant strong, getting, uh,
18 years old.
These lined up on the front row next to
Louis Hamilton who's just the fucking
greatest driver. He just is. He is.
I know Mercedes has the best fucking
cars right now, but you know,
give me a fucking break. It's not like
Ferrari's and sort of a slouch, right?
I Dunno. But you could argue that
Daniel Ricardo's just as good.
He's just not riding. Driving a car was
good. Maybe that's what the fuck it is.
I don't know what it is,
but I really enjoyed yesterday's
race and the previous one. Um,
how do you not love force India
out there with the pink cars?
The few Chicago's
slamming into each other.
It looked like me and my
brother at a fucking carnival.
How you'd be like those two guys are
related. Like you would know. We would,
if we got into bumper cars, we
would know. I didn't give a fuck
about anybody else out there other
than slamming into my own fucking
family member. What was the
point of hitting somebody else?
I couldn't laugh at them in the car
ride home. I'd never see him again. Um,
so anyways, I guess they go to
Singapore next one of these years.
I'm going to line up a standup
date with that race over there. Um,
I'm going to try and go to a couple
of year cause I'm a fucking lunatic.
So I went to Montreal this year and I'm
also going to the race in, um, Austin,
Texas, um, provided
there's not another, uh,
you know, fucking hurricane like that
one that hit Houston. Jesus Christ.
Um,
anyways,
I actually knew I wanted to show
tweet out something. You guys,
there was actually something we could
send like fucking diapers and that type of
stuff for,
I can't just can't imagine it,
but that has babies and everything
he got to take care of. Um,
that seemed like a really cool
thing to do. The very least.
At least you can fucking
dope. So, uh, anyways, I'm
behind with my moto GP racing.
I got to get caught up on that. Um,
but I have to be, I'll be honest, this,
this race in Italy was one of my favorite
races just because of what was going
on in like position four, five and
six fucking lunatic racing. And, uh,
I just wish they could somehow
do something to the cars that,
that happened in the first and
second position because once again,
Lewis Hamilton,
you know,
he gets to the first corner first he comes
out in first place and then that's it.
He's in the front of the race
for the rest of the fucking race.
And then that's just it.
It's over.
He's driving in clean air is cars too
fucking fast now you got to hope that the
car breaks down or he fucks up,
which isn't going to happen. And um,
but I did enjoy all that other stuff,
but a congratulations to Lewis
Hamilton for winning. And another one,
he now is ahead of Sebastian Vettel and
I believe the Mercedes team as a team is
ahead of everybody else too. So
they're fucking crushing it. And a,
I think it's going to be
all downhill from here.
So I'm hoping the fucking Ferrari team
because they're the closest ones can step
it up and a, I like both those
guys. I like Kimmy, Kimmy raking.
It always seems fucking pissed off.
Getting penalties and shit. Um,
I relate to the angry guy,
so that's why like for Cindy,
if they're going to fucking slam
into each other, it's tremendous.
It's tremendous. You know, it's childish.
It's stupid. I love when that guy,
the former race car fucking champion.
I don't know what his name is,
the commentator. He just goes, oh, da
boys boys. What are you doing Dave?
I've had baby gets all like
fucking parental with them.
I wanted to see,
I watched the qualifying too.
I love when it rains out dude.
Oh,
I forgot the greatest quote I've heard
since I started watching formula racing
after the fucking force India
cars hit for the second time.
I think it was that oak on guy.
He says over his radio, he,
stu is fucking
crew chief or whatever. He
goes, what the fuck? Seriously.
What the fuck? Like flip Amy while
he's going like 180 miles an hour.
He sounds like me when I drive to work
and he's doing like, you know, 180,
200 miles an hour and he's done a fucking
flip each other off and they never
flip each. It's, it's, you know, the
European and shit. They give the, hey,
we'll build the blue with the fucking
hand is got to flip somebody off.
You know what I mean?
Or if they're right on their ass,
slam on the breaks like you do on
the highway. Stop fucking tailgating.
I wasn't tailgate. Now is drafting.
All right, enough of this shit.
I know a lot of guys don't
go watch this shit, but um,
alright let's plow ahead here.
I uh,
I was um, did it casino, I
already forget the name of it.
Um, I was in a casino, uh,
right outside of San Diego and a,
I did it two years ago and I
flew down in our 44 and today.
Oh, yesterday I flew in a, uh,
I don't even know what the fuck
it was to be honest with you.
Let me see if I can look up
the name of this helicopter.
This helicopter is turbine engine,
which is a jet engine. And uh,
it was fucking on the whole
thing was hydraulic. Uh, fuck.
Who gives a fuck with what helicopter was.
So basically I trained
on the [inaudible] yard.
22 is like driving a car that has drum
brake, drum brakes, no power steering.
You know what I mean? And you have to
like fucking control the wipers yourself.
You know, like the 1920s,
like Laurel and hardy,
he got to like move it side to side.
Um,
which is also why I love that
thing because you're really flying.
If you're holding a hover, your fucking
doing it, then you move up to the hour 44.
And this is kind of weird
where it's like the uh,
the collective and the cyclic, uh, both
hydraulic. Okay. That's your, your power.
And then I,
you steer the shit you hold with
your hands basically and then you if,
but for whatever reason your foot
pedals are, are, are not hydraulic,
they just manual your own pressure.
So you're dealing with
like really finessing it,
barely having to touch it up top and
then your drum breaks down the bottom.
It's just,
it's a very odd feeling.
And I fly out of Burbank
and there's always a fucking
tailwind when you're going
in to set it down. It's so
fucking annoying. Like right
behind you. Full blast.
I don't know where it comes from.
Um,
every time. In fact, I saw this
student that was learning over there.
What he would do when he, when he
would go to set it down, he would just,
he would just face the wind and set
it down and then go inside and get the
wheels and then put them on the thing
and then just turn the helicopter around.
Uh, as much as it was funny, I was
like, that's a great fucking idea.
I would rather do that, you know, cause
you're landed next to other helicopters.
I don't want to fuck anybody
else's shit up. Sweating. He was,
this thing was like a,
was like a six seater
and a, I got a picture, you know, Dean
del Rey, go look them up on Twitter.
He's teed, tweeted out a picture, I'll
fucking, I'll retweet it. And it's like,
the word is, I'm standing in front of
the coolest helicopter I ever flew in.
I'm talking when somebody, whoever took
the picture. So I look like a fucking,
I may look like an asshole
anyways. Who's kidding? No. Um,
but it was,
I would say the most
amazing machine I've ever
gotten the chance to operate.
And it was like,
it was like a sports car in the air
with like the, like the tightest,
most responsive fucking suspension you
could possibly think of without the rough
ride because you're not on the ground,
you just going through the air.
It didn't feel any turbulence whatsoever.
And um,
I just know when you take off in the
yard 22 when you push the stick forward,
right? I mean, I don't know how
long it is. It's a good eight,
nine seconds until you want to get
up to 53 knots. That's the optimal,
you know,
speed to get out to get the most rate
of climb and it takes you a good,
I feels like forever eight, nine
seconds, this fucking thing.
It was like maybe two and a half seconds.
Then it was up to speed.
You just pull the stick back
and you fucking shot up in
the air. I've never been,
it was really intimidating, but once I
just sorta w I watched my instructor,
I've two times through the start and start
up and shut down of it and it's like,
it's, it's not that bad.
It's just intimidating at
first and, and then you get,
once you know where to look,
which is basically your manifold pressure,
your altitude and how fast you're going.
And then I'll see you trim once,
you know where those are, all the
other shit. It's just like, well,
you know a fucking horns going to go
off if there's a problem anywhere else.
Right.
Anyways,
it was fun as shit and he went
down and we did the GIG and I'm,
I think I'm going to start doing that.
Like I'm,
I'm doing a podcast festival for the
all things comedy network in the end of
October and if I don't get
this acting Gig and I'm in La,
I'm going to fly out in a helicopter.
I got to Vegas Gig,
I'm going to do that one in the
helicopter too. And that way I can get my,
keep my hours up, stay current and
a while going out, making money.
So I'm renting the helicopter, but
I'm earning money right. And in,
in a way I get the fly private without
having to blow all this money on a
fucking stupid ass jet,
which is stupid, right?
It was fucking private jets is fucking
stupid as hell you're getting in them.
You can't even stand up. It's the
dumbest thing ever. You're way better.
You can spend one 90th the money on a
first class fucking ticket and you are in
a year on like a fucking cruise ship.
You can stand,
you can stand up when you take a piss.
You don't have to bend over
at the fucking neck, you know?
I know they make bigger jets, but
those things are like, you know you,
you're going to fly from Boston to Rhode.
It's going to cost you like a fucking
$300,000. I don't know how people,
I don't know anybody flies private to be
honest with you. I have no fucking idea.
Just go to a mom and pop airport.
Get on jet blue or virgin.
That's the way to do it. You some miles,
bump yourself up to a bigger seat.
You're going to get a pilot
who was psyched. He's making
a ton of fucking money.
You get on those little ones, those
that people and I'm making shit. Right.
I know that's been, that's been
my experience. They're trying to,
they're trying to get a gig flying one
of the bigger ones so they can actually
make money instead of flying
some little fucking six seater.
Yeah.
You know what it is?
I'm out of my fucking element.
I don't know what to
think about that shit.
I just have heard about how much it
fucking costs. Uh, all right, let me, uh,
let me read the, um, let
me read the fucking, uh,
advertising here for this week. Uh,
all right. Why don't we got here? Oh,
draft kings, everybody gay. Do
you like to gamble on sports?
You want to make some fucking money?
These are the guys.
It's not too late to get closer to the
game you love with draft kings one week
fantasy football.
This Sunday draft kings is
hosting a $100,000 pick, um,
contest that is totally free to enter.
All right,
pick them is the newest way to pull
play one week. Fantasy football.
Drafting your team is faster than ever.
Draftkings has organized
players into eight tears.
All you have to do is select
one player from each tier.
Choose between public contests,
choose between public contest with big
cash prizes or private contests where con
private contest, sorry. Or you can
compete against a group of your friends.
Draft kings also has a beginner and
casual contests where you can play against
people of a similar skill level.
The best part is you get to draft a new
team each week without any commitment,
so get to drive canes.com now and use
Promo Code Burr to play and draft kings
free contests with the hundred thousand
dollars dollars in total prices this
Sunday. Use my promo code bur
bur to play for free this Sunday.
That's Promo Code [inaudible]
at draftkings.com eligibility
restrictions apply.
See draftkings.com for details. Speaking
of which, the New England patriots,
the five times Superbowl
defending champions,
um,
the,
the off the often criticized for
absolutely no fucking reason.
You know,
all the time I had another guy bring up
fucking deflate gate. I always tell them,
it's like they did not get convicted
of deflating balls. You fucking moron.
Yeah.
That was laughed out of court
for the 90000000th time.
And then the suspension
was, was, was canceled.
Remember that he was supposed to be
suspended and they took it to court and it
was laughed out of court. And
the judge said, you're waste.
Why did you waste my fucking time
with this? That's what happened.
And then you know,
the United States of America,
you cannot get tried twice
for the same offense.
That's a habeas hearsay
something or other, right? You can't be,
you can't be fucking double jeopardy.
You can't fucking do that.
So the NFL found a loophole.
They just went back to court and
said, uh, is the NFL Corporation?
And the judge was like,
yes. And then they said,
does a corporation had the
right to suspend its employee?
And the judge said yes.
And they said, fine, we're corporation.
Tom Brady is our employee and he is
suspended. And that's what they did.
That's why he got suspended. Not because
they proved anything. You fucking dopes.
And by the way, the guy will cut
the d, the alleged, by the way,
under inflated fucking ball.
By the way,
the cults also allegedly had 200
flaming balls. But who gives a fuck?
Then I went and all the championships,
right? The guy caught the ball,
tested positive for steroids
this past season. Ah, nobody
gives a shit. All right.
Loot crate everybody.
Luke Craig,
be the envy of your friends and get 100%
exclusive crates at [inaudible] dot com
slash x x x and enter my code x x,
X.
Well, I guess I got the
wrong fucking copy, didn't I?
Uh, I dunno what to do with this exec.
What is this? I never know
what this fucking God, boy,
I'm just going to read it
and get x, x, x amount of dollars off
any new subscription. September's loot.
Crate theme is robotic
on a quest for epic gear,
housewares and collectibles.
Loot crate has it.
Loot crate offers an epic range of pop
culture items for less than $20 a month.
If you're more of a fanatical fashion.
He stood then try loot
where monthly wearable and
accessories with cult classics
in your favorite franchises.
If you want to get fancy getting bigger
box and an even bigger loop with Luke
Craig DX, want to geek out
your pet. Try loop pets.
Offer expires September
19th at 9:00 PM Pacific.
Whether they beep or speak.
Many of your favorite characters are
robotic and September is Luke rate.
You'll find items from star wars,
Star Trek, aliens in blade runner.
We see of those robot. Second
named c three p. O r Two d two
r five d four. That's
a, that's a good one.
That's like naming an offensive lineman.
Uh,
then there was at one on fucking buck
Rogers, some of that stupid thing.
Bidi Bidi Bidi Bidi member
that before talk to go.
Bidi Bidi Bidi Bidi and
they would say something.
I'd never understood it.
Somebody sat in a writer's
room and pitch that one.
If the robot said Bidi Bidi Bidi Bidi
and then said what he was going to say,
it's somehow there wasn't like a
deafening amount of silence. It'd be like,
what the fuck did you just say?
Get out of this rough. Alright,
one lucky subscriber will also,
when a mega crate of seriously epic,
you have until the 19th September 19th
at 9:00 PM Pacific to subscribe and
receive that month's crate. And when the
cut off happens that it's, that's it,
it's over.
Go to Luke,
rate.com/burn and enter my code bur bur
to save $3 off on any new subscription
today. I wish I had more information
on that, but I don't. Um,
all right, here we go. What do we
got? An Oh, Buddha to me undies.
Me undies. Who remembers our
five d four bu do, do Mondays.
Mondays they even make them for the
Horse Nice and soft up against your Twat.
You know,
you fucking love it.
Don't say it's not nice and comfy up
against your snatch and they make him even
for your ball bag. They'll take
out the wrinkles. Um, all right,
me undies. You want to look good in your
underwear and be comfortable, right?
Right.
But that perfect balance is hard to find.
Don't sacrifice style or comfort.
Checkout me,
Andy's dot com and find the best
pair of underwear in the world.
Talk about why me on these is the
best underwear you will ever own.
Feel free to improvise. Jesus. Cry.
I don't fucking know because it feels
good up against your under carriage.
You know what I mean? You know when you
go to buy a car and then they go, hey,
you want to, you want to get the fucking
undercoating. This is the undercoating.
You know you buy a pair of pants,
right?
What are you going to have you to have
you fucking Levi's chafe and up against
your junk?
He can't have that.
I'm going to be great if there was
some fucking soft velvety Greg Louganis
speedo type of underwear out there with
thank God there is with me undies for
the Fellas,
me undies,
diamonds seen pouch like
a rhinestone bowl bag.
Cradles your jewels and it gives you
stuff to support it needs without feeling
too tight. You know I love about
that song rhinestone cowboy.
I love when he goes, uh, what does the
liver as Tall Cam, I don't know. I don't,
I don't that, that, that,
that the total oh yeah.
And he goes and offers come in over
the phone offers coming over the phone.
You only have to,
you have to be in fucking show business
or be self employed to know how great
that line is offers coming over the
phone after years of having your hat and
your hand begging the fucking do anything
to finally get to that level where
people actually want you and you
get to stand there and be like,
you like me to really like me.
All right,
so you got diamond encrusted balls,
right?
Ladies will love this
soft ecofriendly fabric.
What did my screen go?
So soft and touchable.
Gross 100% satisfaction guarantee.
I don't know why they talk about their
fucking pussies and they have so soft and
touchable.
It makes me feel like a creep.
I a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee.
So off that touch upon the
guarantee you will love,
we guarantee they guarantee
that you'll love your, uh,
your undies or your money back right now.
Me and he's half is an exclusive offer
for just my listeners and anybody else.
They advertise with the fucking horse.
Get 20% off your first pair
and free shipping and the
undies is so sure you will
love your, their underwear. They
even offer 100% satisfaction.
Guarantee your order, you order a pair.
And if you don't love your first pair,
get a full refund.
This is a no brainer to try 20% off
free shipping and 100% satisfaction
guarantee. What fuck are you waiting
for? Fuck. Are you waiting for bud?
Uh, you want to have soft nuts under your
fucking overalls and you got your bunk
shocking, that little front pocket.
So that would have front pockets,
foreign overalls,
that little thing there.
Is that where they put their
buck shot? Um, it's great.
It's nice and snug doesn't fall out
when I'm on the four way. Look, a,
this is limited.
This is a limited time offer.
So what the fuck are you waiting for?
Start wearing the best goddamn
underwear of your life.
It changed my life evidently
according to the copy.
It's time to let me undies change yours.
Go to me undies.com/burr
right fucking now. All right.
Dollar Shave club dude.
Oh my God.
They never proved that the
balls were underinflated.
Um, every which they
didn't by the way, uh,
everyone knows dollar shave club
ships amazing raises for a few bucks.
What you might not know is that dollar
shave club also has products to pretty
much, uh, for pretty much everything
else you need in the bathroom. Body Wash,
shampoo, Hair Gel, lip balm,
everything at the store.
There are too many options and you can't
tell the difference between any of them.
It's overwhelming. You feel like Robin
Williams in Moscow on the Hudson,
right when he walks into the grocery
store and he fucking faints and he sticks
his head up that girls
dress. You remember that, um,
at the store that too many options.
You can't tell Azalea already said that.
All right.
Then if you have any questions to clerk
usually doesn't know the difference and
usually can't fucking find them cause
they got a skeleton crew at nine in the
morning now. Um, then an implicit
not experts on the products.
Dollar Shave Club's makes it easy and
convenient for you to upgrade your shave
and your bathroom.
Now you don't have to step foot in a
store to get high quality shave and
grooming products. Dollar Shave Club
delivers them right to your door. Uh,
if you're sick of the
nonsense at the store,
now's the time to try dollar
Shave Club for limited time.
Dollar Shave Club is basically
giving away their shit. Shower,
shave, start a cassette to new members.
This is why I Love Dollar Shave Club.
They just put curses in there.
They got to shit. Shower,
shave started set for
new members for only $5.
This start set features their executive
razor. This is just brilliant.
This is just for else single guys
shit, shower, shave. There you go.
Pack it all up and three
trial size versions of their
most popular products that
help you stay fresh and clear and clean,
so fresh and so clean.
And your first box you would see if I
can shave butter bodywash and one wipe
Charlies one way Challis but wipes,
you will also receive their
executive razor,
which includes their
premium weighted hand,
weighty handle and full
cassette of cartridges.
After the first box replacement cartridges
are sent for only a few bucks a month.
This offers exclusively
available@dollarshaveclub.com slash burr.
That's dollar Shave club.com Della
Shave club's high quality products.
We'll have you covered from phase to
cheek to butt cheeks from face cheeks to
buttcheek. Sorry. There's no better time
to fucking try the club now.
My God, there's still one
more. Sorry. Pro Flowers,
pro flowers with the fee.
Get some flowers for Labor Day.
Talk about the last time he spontaneously
surprise someone with something
completely unexpected and how it felt.
Um,
I remember I stuck this gun in this
little kid's face one time and I was like,
I'm gonna fucking kill you.
And his parents were freaking
out and uh, oh my God.
Did I laugh?
Talk about what the Rose Bouquet recently
sent to you by profiles look like in
all your overall impression of
it. Well, I didn't get one and uh,
so I have no impression of
it. Sounds Nice. Maybe Andrew.
Got It. Do you have any more requests
than, can I just read this shit?
Proflowers wants to help you surprise
someone for no reason at all while also
surprising you with this special
deal. For my listeners, know,
proflowers wants to sell flowers during
months when you don't have to sell them.
You don't and you have, do you know what
the fuck it by him. That's why they want,
and we want you to buy our
shit. Just say it. Listen,
we got a ton of fucking flowers
left over from mother's Day.
Can you buy these things before they die?
We got a great fucking deal for you.
And if you fucking give them to your
wife for no goddamn reason at all,
she's probably gonna blow you.
Okay?
This is what should be in the copy.
Instead of this get 20% off any of
their unique summer rose bouquets or any
other boot bouquet for $29 they're
colorful. Rainbow Roses are always a hit,
and if you aren't sure what
to send someone profiles,
boot cares are guaranteed to
last at least seven days. Guys,
just fucking do this for your
wife. It's easy. All right,
go to proflowers.com use my code name
bar. Do you want to get a blow job? I May.
Maybe a little handy at the fuck and I
hop under the table to make the table a
little more sticky. Gross. Sorry.
This is what you need to do.
All the dopes. Buy Flowers on mother's
Day. They buy them on fucking, you know,
birthdays and they buy them on,
on, on fucking Valentine's Day.
All right?
If you want to up your blow jobs,
if you want to stay up in
the pros and hit 300 okay,
you got to spray it all over the field.
All right, so one of these times you just,
she's just, yeah, it's August
or is it September? Yeah. Cep,
who gets their fucking wife or
girlfriend flowers in September.
Nobody be the person that fucking does it.
And get your Dick sucked today.
Alright, there you go. All right.
Booze lineup. Oh, beautiful.
I was hoping people are going to
send these in. All right. I um,
I talked last week and you know, I get
back into baseball and, uh, Yankees,
red sox things heating up again.
We've been meet in the playoffs.
It's has to happen. It's
been too fucking long. Um,
I ended up fucking Yankees
took three out of four,
so I broke even all this shit talk and
all of this fucking shit talking and it
just, we ended up just being even, um,
but I was talking about, you
know, just watching baseball.
I did my booze lineup of like whiskeys,
scotches, and bourbons. All right.
I don't just do scotches. Okay.
This isn't like the fucking,
this is an MLB when Babe Ruth
played. All right, this is Emmy.
Anybody could show up as long as you
brown now of Tequilas also welcome.
Um, so this would be my lineup.
Uh, I always changed the lineup.
I would say this week, uh, Johnny
Walker blue is leading off.
You've got to start with some strong shit,
right?
Pappy van Winkle is in
second and then I would put,
uh,
Angel's envy if Third
Mccallum rare casts.
Rare cask is bad and clean up.
All right? Then I'd have Yippy Kai, Yay.
Fifth.
And then once you get to the middle,
Lord,
this is just when I just want to get
fucked up. Right. Those other ones,
Angel's envy is also a good one
just to get fucked up on, you know,
it's not that expensive either.
Then you get to the middle of the order,
but it's like I'm staying at home and I'm
getting drunk by myself or I'm getting
drunk with a friend of mine that
it appreciates good whiskey,
bourbon or whatever. When I get in the
middle, then it's like Yippy Kai. Yay.
Patrones silver. Maybe I put grand
patrol where I put angel's envy.
That's why I got that.
Okay.
Grant Tron it fucking the
third spot denigrate yet BKI.
Yay. Then I got fucking angel's
envy and then Johnny Walker Black.
Okay.
Those are the next three. So then he got
eight and nine, and that's when you know,
you just have fucking,
yeah,
just people coming over and they just
want to get shit faced and you just got to
go maker's mark of
fucking, uh, Jack Daniels,
you know? And then if you just
have a complete fucking shithead,
do you just give him bread label?
Fucking Johnny Walker. All right,
so here's this person's booze
lineup. All right? He goes,
I love your idea about doing a
booze alcohol battling line up.
Here's my submission leading off
Kentucky Tavern. I'd never heard of this.
This is what I love is going to
give me new shit to try. Dependable,
a little rough around the edges,
but you know,
this guy's going to get
on base at a 400 clip,
even if he has to lean into one
every now and then. I loved it.
This person broke it all down.
They'd give me a scouting reports too.
When you send these in
batting second core needles,
what the fuck is that? Horn. Ito's uh,
can be streaky at times but
still has a little bit of a pop.
If you mix it with grapefruit soda
to Jersey and your second guy,
you're already mixing it with something.
All right. Oh Shit. Hang on a second.
Speaking of that,
some Josh just asked me if I had soda.
No I don't.
I got to do a voice text here.
Get the Phanta orange
with the Mexican sugar.
There you go. All right. That's
right when I'm fucking not boozing.
I actually drink Phanta orange soda.
It's kind of nice cause it's really sweet.
And then he got the smoke.
You know, it's not redundant.
Remember big night when that lady got the
pasta and then she also ordered mashed
potatoes and the guy wouldn't do it
cause it was two starches. You know,
why would you have a cigar and
then drink something really PD.
It's like fucking redundant. You want
some, a sweet kind of alcohol? I'm
fucking with you. I'm not actually
I do. Okay. So batting third,
this guy has bullet,
this is your franchise player.
He makes everyone around
him a little better place.
He's going to give you a team friendly,
longterm contract that won't
have you paying luxury taxes.
Do this guy's great. You know, we took
a funny idea. Now he's taken it to,
we didn't even funnier level.
All I did was just get,
I got to break down each player now.
Alright, batting cleanup, Knob Creek.
He goes, can you tell him a bourbon
drinker? I can never keep them straight.
He goes, bottom line is if there's
any ducks slept on the pond,
this guy is there to deliver it in
the knockout punch. I got to tell you,
the way he's describing this lineup,
he's definitely making the playoffs,
if not fucking winning the pennant.
A batting fifth Smirnoff vodka.
Okay.
Definitely nothing to write home about,
but when surrounded with
the right personnel, there's
always potential for magic.
You know what my vodka is? My go to
vodka. I like Belvedere, old Belvedere,
I've come here, boy, I liked that better
than grey goose. Grey goose is just like,
that's like soft rock, like
easy listening. You know what
I mean? I like Belvedere.
It's got a little more
of a fucking bite to it.
But I don't know much about because either
a batting six, Johnnie Walker black.
Now you might be, uh, now might be a
good time dimension. I'm in my early 30.
[inaudible] thank you.
As this guy is a September call up,
you're not quite ready to add them
to your 40 man roster just yet,
but he's for a cup of buddies
up for a cup of coffee.
But cause you know he's going to be an
important part of your future. Yeah.
Maybe can get on base and steal
second. All right. Batting seventh.
Oh Jesus do this is unforgivable.
If you're in your thirties,
this is unforgivable and I respect you
that you can still drink this Yeager or
meister. Wow. Wow.
You often find yourself wondering why
this guy is even still around and yet you
feel you can you wait and yet you can,
you feel like you can remember a time
when he was actually pretty good. Yeah.
He's like the fucking, uh, one
of those guys we had just like,
you know, like Vince Carter is still
play. That's not fair to Vince Carter.
Cause Vince Carter was one of
the greatest fucking, you know,
I think the best dunker
of all fucking time.
High of certainly the highest jumper.
I Apologize,
I shouldn't have said Vince Carter was
the first guy thought of ease, like a, uh,
uh,
up.
Do you remember when like GRB was
playing on the Colorado Rockies?
It's like one of those deals. All
right, Captain Morgan batting eighth,
definitely a role player. This,
this, that's like your catcher.
This guy could be a superstar,
but he's got a bit of a sweet tooth
and always shows up to spring training,
20 pounds overweight, always
the panda still, you know,
he's good for a sac fly and
a key situation. Yeah. One
of these guys just has to,
you're out there for defense, you know,
he's not hitting for average. Alright.
Batting ninth, wild
Turkey, American honey.
And he writes old geezers.
Uh,
you ask him to lay down a bunt and you
just know he's going to hit into an
inning ending double play every
damn time. Uh, by the way, if it's,
if it's a close one,
I'm putting in buffalo trace in place
of Jaeger as a defensive substitution.
Do this guy's brilliant. Uh, so
that's my lineup. Thanks for the idea.
I enjoyed putting this together.
Even if you don't read it now, Dude,
I love that you broke it all down. All
right, here's another guys line up.
All right. His whiskey lineup,
bullet, Eagle, rare batting,
third macallan 12 batting
forth angel's envy,
cask strength.
I never had that.
D h a I might fuck up some
of the names of these.
Yeah.
Uh, Bell Bell Veni 12 years. Single Malt.
Glen Levitt, French Oak. I can't deal
with the florals. I don't like the floors.
I like more of the PD thing. Like Glenn
Leberts. I never been able to, uh,
quite handles,
but I respect them.
They are definitely in the
hall of fame of boots. Um,
oh fuck. He's going to stop by a Taco. Oh,
Jesus Christ. What is he
talking about? No, fuck.
He's going to start by a taco truck to
get the fucking booze. The Soto. I mean,
hang on, let me hit pause and straighten
this up. All right, I'm back. So anyways,
uh, Glen Levitt, French
oak, six number seven,
Willie Pot, still reserve. Never
heard of that one. Number eight,
Jefferson's ocean aged at sea.
Jesus.
Sounds like low tide shit to me.
Number nine,
Hudson Bay starting pitcher is blends.
I've got to do a starting
pitcher. Middle Reliever, uh,
giving you a row or
reliable couple innings.
Maker's 46 closer is
Alijah Craig barrel proof.
Dude, I love everybody going
with the starting pitchers.
Then you got to have your
middle [inaudible]. You had
middle relief. Oh my God,
Dude. This is, this is endless.
And then you don't see,
you're going to get some real big
time. Booze Hound. Step nine, you know,
positions in the batting lineup
are not going to be enough.
They're going to have to go
take enough to like, I dunno,
do like a football team.
11 offensive players.
This isn't fair to people over in Europe.
Go ahead,
give me your fucking lineups and use
all the fucking soccer terminology.
Maybe I'll learn something. All right
is another nut. Last booze line up here.
Dear Billy, no fun, no fuss, no Muss,
no brainer in answer to your request
for our batting lineups of booze.
I'm not much of a drinker anymore,
so I'll go the other way and
do my recreational drug lineup.
I love it. I love it. You guys had
taken this idea and run with it.
This is tremendous. All right. Number one,
weed number two,
black hash,
preferably from Naipaul.
Number three, magic mushrooms.
Batting cleanup, LSD, preferably purple.
Owsley never tried it,
but according to Ken Casey,
it was the best number five
x to see pure and uncut.
Number six have mine. I don't want
it. This number. Seven cocaine,
pure and uncut. Cocaine. Pure and
up unconscious should be fucking.
That sounds like a speedster,
man.
Get them on base to fucking
steal second and you have LSD.
Fucking bring them home with
a single to right. I Dunno.
Running on a full count.
You're not going to catch that guy.
He might score from first. All
right, number eight, peyote.
Payoti number nine
Mescalin pure and uncut.
Hey Bill on Thursday, you were talking
about the sound of drums in the 70s.
I watched this recently and thought it
would be informative to you over overhead
Mike with a compressor on it. Um, you guys
have to watch this. If you're in, into
any type of music.
I actually watched this thing and it's,
do you know that sound
of a Phil Collins Drums,
the famous drum fill from
in the air tonight that Gaga
Goenka going good, don't,
don't, don't. And it was,
you got to watch this video,
how they came up with that drum sound was
an accident and then everybody used it
and it literally became the sound
of the eighties and now it's back.
I guess Taylor swift used it in
some song called 1989 and all that.
But if you just,
if you're into that nerdy audio stuff,
like I find this is how great my
fucking drunk teacher Davey Lich is.
I, I was tuning up my, my drums, you know,
I got some back east and it says
old Slingerland kit and it's, uh,
a third, uh, 12, no, a nine by 13, 14,
and an 18. It was 13, 14,
Tom's and then an 18 inch
floor and a 24 inch kick.
And I ended up adding
another s I found, uh, uh,
from the same era of 16 inch floor Tom.
And then I added another bass drum,
so I got to 24. So, all right,
this is my first attempt to get to try
to get away from just aping and doing a
bad job of everything John Bonham did.
I was getting into Primus and my brothers,
they were playing like speed metal and
shit and they were trying to always
trying to get me into Metallica,
slayer and all them. And I just,
I just was too much of a fucking idiot
to realize how great that music was.
And I could've seen all those bands on
their first tours and I didn't do it. Um,
so anyways,
uh,
I went home and I was
tuning up the bass drum and
I just couldn't get a good fucking sound
and it was this weird like vibrating
fucking sound or whatever.
And I text my teacher, I said,
yeah, I'm getting this weird,
like a buzzer or a rattle. And he said,
is there a hole in the front head?
And I was like, this guy is a
fucking genius, fucking genius.
Cause what happened is there
wasn't a hole in the front head,
but where they were, something fell on it
and puncture just the littlest of hole.
I said it was a tiny little,
it goes,
that would be enough to fuck it up
cause I couldn't get that boom sound.
And um, so now I'm like
obsessing about it. I gotta get,
I gotta get back east again. I want
to try tuning them up again. And um,
I've now become obsessed
with like different heads.
And I used to be so afraid
to try and tune my drums.
I'd have somebody else do it and
then I just wouldn't touch him.
And I played him until they sucked again.
And then I hope I could find
somebody else rather than,
than just biting the
bullet and being like,
just take out your drum key and start
fucking with it and ask people who know
how to do it to teach you how to do it
and keep fucking doing it. You asshole.
Well, you know, part of it being an
asshole as you don't do shit like that.
All right. Pocalypse hey
there, dilly dilly. Hey there,
Billy death bell.
Uh,
the Internet keeps talking about the
end of times as if things today are far
worse than they've ever been.
I'm only 31 years old,
but I seem to remember plenty of
bad weather and shitty presidents.
MMM.
There's this need to make everything
sound worse than it is these days because
everyone loves to be the bearer of
bad news and they get a thrill off the
excitement that shit may
be going south real quick,
I saw a quote by John Mayer on Twitter.
Someone asked him what annoys him?
And he says,
spacious argument.
It's everywhere. I can't stand
it. Is that I say that right?
The Fed is eight.
The Federation of Defense
Attorney logic gone mainstream.
Ugh. Well he's obviously a smarter person
than me cause I don't want any of that
means spacious argument.
It's everywhere.
I can't stand at the Federation of
Defense Attorney logic gone mainstream.
That right there is why he's a brilliant
guitars because I don't know what the
fuck he just did,
but I don't,
I don't know that anybody's ever
put words together like that.
I don't know what that
means. Uh, I totally agree.
Everyone thinks they're dropping the mic
and they're just pandering and reaching
for low hanging fruit now
that, that I agree with. Yes.
A PS keep the nineties music coming.
That Fiona Apple Song that Andrew
used last week reminded of the summer
I started jerking off save
the pet store manager from,
from last week. I don't know what that
means. Yeah. Andrew picks the music.
I wish I was could claim a that I was
as cool as to know all this shit that he
does. He knows a bunch
about music. Um, yeah,
there is a lot of that.
There's a lot of gloom and doom and all
that type of shit. But, uh, you know,
it's not all it is. I, you know,
the Great Barrier Reef and all that
type of shit is pretty terrifying. Oh,
that shit is pretty fucking
terrifying. And, uh, I mean,
I can't even focus on it if you
actually get past all the dope.
So on social media talking about things
and you actually listened to scientists
talking about like whatever
their predictions are. Um,
I know that there's, I don't know,
this sounds like a, you know,
I think it's going to be a, I
know, it should be interesting.
We'll see. I hope that wrong.
You know, who the fuck knows?
I don't know. All right.
The DNC,
everybody day or Mr. Byrd,
I'm appalled and disgusted
that you had the Addis,
a Udacity to speak poorly
of Debbie Shults Wasserman,
a lifelong servant of her
country and the only party, uh,
that has moved this country forward.
I usually enjoy your brand of humor.
There's no way this person's series,
I've see,
I have see parts of your comedy specials
and overheard a handful of episodes of
your podcast while in the
proxy of my brother in law.
Uh,
you sir,
have a responsibility to tell the truth
and not just your uninformed opinions on
politics.
The deceit that you distribute is
going to aid in the dismantling of this
country. Oh God. Oh God.
Give me a fucking break.
You just happened to be walking by
and you heard that he, well, you know,
the whole part of this podcast
is that I am uninformed.
MMM.
And I sent a link that you could watch
on Youtube and listen to that lawyer
discussing,
okay.
The things that she did or didn't do.
So I don't know what you fucking problem
is. You know, I talk about politics.
The way I talk about sports is someone
who never did it at a professional level.
I, Matt Schiltz Wasserman,
a few years back,
and I asked her what we could do every
day to change the nation for the better.
And she eloquently said,
do not let them tell you how to feel.
Oh God.
All right. I'm not reading the
rest of this. This is fucking
sincerely a proud Democrat
who will not be discouraged.
You know what you sound like.
You sound like someone, you know,
when someone comes up to me and says the
Patriots are cheaters and then I say,
who's your team?
And then I talk about the shit that
they've done and then they downplay that.
Yeah, you are. I gotta be honest
with you is uninformed as I am.
Um, people like you, I can't
even talk to because you're so lost in
your blue ties that you can't see that
it's this,
you know what it's like
everybody out here in Hollywood loves
to sit there and Trash Fox News and talk
about how they're all these bullies and
all that. And I'm going to tell you,
I'm not gonna name any fucking names,
but the amount of performers,
comedians, actresses, and
all this type of shit,
like their level of zero tolerance.
Like there,
they are literally what they're fighting,
they're bullies.
They tell people how they're supposed to
think the way they're supposed to think.
And they feel that they are 100% right.
They feel that their view of the world
is the way that the world should be.
And anyone who doesn't think
that needs to be attacked,
it needs to be dragged on stage and
humiliated needs to have their, their,
their ability to earn a living attacked.
It's no difference than when you watched
what Fox News did, did the Dixie chicks,
it's the exact same fucking thing,
the exact same level of righteousness,
patting themselves on the back about how
fucking smart they are and how informed
they are,
you know,
meanwhile as they fly around and fucking
private jets, give me a fucking break.
Give me a fucking break.
Okay.
You know
the Patriots Cheat your team, Cheech.
The Republican's are pieces of shit.
The Democrats are pieces of shit.
Alright, there you go. There you go.
So it,
other than anything other than that,
you're looking at shit through
fucking rose colored glasses. And um,
I think it's,
I think that that is a,
I don't know what to think. I just, I
can't have a conversation with that.
You know what I mean?
It's like if I listen to a red sox fan
back when Derek Jeter was playing and
they just say that he sucks and he's
fucking overrated and blah, blah,
and I would just sit there and be
like that he is, and he's fucking one,
one of the greatest players of all time.
I'd love if he was on my team, you know,
I hate the Yankees, but I, I'm
not going to hate on greatness.
Okay.
Mariano Rivera is the greatest
fucking closer of all time.
I still fucking hate the Yankees,
but I don't hate him to
a level that I can't see.
I can't see that. You know
what I mean? I just don't,
I just don't fucking understand it.
I don't understand it.
Like you want to talk about spygate and
the Patriots were guilty of cheating to
Flight Cape was bullshit.
Spygate was true. However,
they were only guilty of
doing it for one game.
And I only clarify that
because everybody thinks, well,
they should take away all their titles
because that's what they were doing. No,
that was the first game. It was illegal
and they kept fucking doing it. All right,
and they will 100% guilty and they deserve
to be fucking fine because they were
cheating then. Yes,
they were that one time.
All the other stuff was bullshit though.
However, if they, cause I'm a wanting to,
flaka came out, I was like,
if they did this shit again,
I'm done with this fucking team.
That's what I said.
And then I watched the whole fucking
thing unfold and I was like, oh,
this was just bullshit.
So there you go.
Does that sound evenhanded you guys
probably think I'm too much of a patriots
fan, but I mean I did it. They spygate
was cheating and they were guilty.
They did it one game.
Raymond Janie fucking ratted them out.
Then that was it. They will fucking
guilty. What are you going to do?
Does that make them worse than anybody
else? No. Bill Walsh fucking cheated.
So there you go.
They should,
Democrats and the Republicans say the
Patriots of Democrats. I'm a patriots fan,
so I am a democrat. Okay.
But I can see their fucking,
I can see that spygate was fucking
cheating and they were guilty of it.
And I could also see that Bill Walsh
fucking did the same thing when he
pretended his fucking headsets went up.
It's not that fucking hard.
Um, I don't understand what your
point is that the, Oh my God,
this person that used to fuck
you meeting proves, you know,
they see what should we do?
Easy.
Don't let them capital's tell you
how to feel that is such like,
that is going to be the most vague.
I'm on my way to my town car
fucking horseshit response ever.
Hey Bill.
Uh,
what's your secret to being as
successful standup comedian?
Uh, you know, just get out
there and keep doing it, man.
All right,
girlfriend won't take racist last name.
All right, dear bills burry. Doughboy
Hey, fuck you man. I'm under one 80. Okay,
go easy. Go easy. You know. All right,
dear bill's very doughboy.
Uh,
my girlfriend of three years has
made it very clear that if we were,
if I were to propose to her that
she would not take my last name.
The reason being is that she
feels my last name is racist.
The name is coons, spelled c. O. N. S.
I told her that I have never encountered
a problem having this last name and she
has nothing to worry about.
Thoughts. Yeah. Here's my thoughts.
I think you're making this
up and if you're not, um,
that woman is too dumb to
Mary and reproduce with.
All right.
If you call a black person
a coon that is racist,
if you're last name is coons,
it isn't,
you know, look, I see. If your last
name was the n word, then yeah. I mean,
maybe you want to, you know, yeah. I mean,
if it's, I don't know. I mean, if
that's your fucking last thing,
I think that's a believable last name,
isn't it?
You know what I mean?
I Dunno. Anyways, my roommate is, you
know, I like, I'm trying to think,
I'm trying to think of a fucking racial
group I can do here without getting in
trouble.
Cause I want to really do a fucking,
I guess I'd have to go against my own,
my own fucking racist
or would I do if there's no good ones,
there is no good ones with white people
cause like it doesn't have an effect on
us.
Okay.
Yeah. Shit. You know what
I mean? I don't know.
Maybe in the future of some other group
takes over and then we'll have that.
We'll have our, you know, you
can't call me cracker. Um,
I love crackers. I love putting cheese
on. My roommate is a fucking Weirdo,
dear conti. Mcconn fuck. First of all,
a big fan of the fucking podcast,
the last fucking Netflix special
was phenomenal. So thanks. Okay.
Now this is one of these
people that thinks,
because I swear that
now they have to swear.
You don't have to bring yourself
down to my level, sir. Anyways,
I just fucking moved into college as a
freshman roommate is a hot motherfucker.
I mean, I'm gay. So right
away I was into him,
but I kept to myself since I had
no way of knowing he was gay too.
I thought you guys had Gaydar
you couldn't sense it. Um,
so last week on Friday after
a fucking drunken night out,
we returned to our room.
Oh Geez. Here we go.
And the fucking guy
offhandedly tells me he's gay.
Once the conversation started
getting more personal,
then I told them I'm also
gay and this guy says fag,
I don't think this is real.
After which we proceeded to fuck,
which was fucking amazing.
By the way. I find the term,
I find the fag term and Deering so
fuck all the political correctness,
hysteria by gays and non gaze alike
are,
I'm just going to read
this. Okay. Anyways,
this is when the shit started to hit
the fan. No Pun intended. Sorry Dude.
You lobbed it over the fucking net.
Um,
once I came he expressed disappointment
at the volume of my comp.
Does anyone believe this is true? The
fucker literally said, that's it. What?
Are you sick or something?
I felt fucking inadequate sense.
His load was considered
really bigger than mine.
Oh Jesus Christ. So then the next
morning he says he wants to fuck again.
I go along with it like, he's
so hot, I'm not going to refuse.
Halfway through this motherfucker
says, you know, for a tall guy,
you sure have a small Dick. And he
writes like, walk the fuck. Yeah.
Well Dude, you came back for more
abuse here. So I'm all for two, right?
Inadequate Dick size check,
lack of Herculean cum shot check,
uh,
is insulting the people.
He fucks part of his style.
Like I can't figure out why
he still wants to fuck me.
You have to two colossal fucking insults.
So what the fuck do I do next?
So stop fucking the guy.
Fuck knows. But the next day
we're chugging peers in our room,
you know, other than the gay sex,
this sounds amazing that, sorry,
I'm looking at this as a straight guy.
Um,
what the fuck am I? Uh, okay,
we're chugging beers. Roman.
He suggests something beyond weird.
Oh God.
He's basically tells me He wants
me to pee in his mouth. You know,
even if this is fake, this is tremendous.
See Korean if you got to give this up,
okay. Since it turns him,
since it turns a mom, um,
eight beers deep and I'm a lightweight,
so I'm like fuck it dude.
I swear to God if this is true and you
piss in this guy's mouth and he's like,
oh awesome. Well that's it.
This motherfucker has a stream,
like a God damn fire hose and
nearly broke my jaw and the process.
What?
I don't believe that Jesus Christ.
So I'm completely weirded out
by this colossal cont dude.
You let them piss in your mouth.
His only saving grace is that he happens
to be the hottest guy I ever met.
So bill, what the fuck do
I do? Do I change from,
kicked this con to the curb and sleep
I never sleep with again or do I stick
stick in there so that I can
stick it in there. Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
You Mcgee Bitch.
Okay.
I Dunno.
It sounds like you feel bad afterwards.
If I was with a woman and she was doing
this shit to me and she was really hot,
yeah, I'd probably keep going back, but I
would just get myself mentally prepared.
You know what you might do?
Just telling me as a weird ass hole.
Okay.
You got to get in his head.
Tell her mama is acids to Harry. He
needs to braid the hair on his ass. Who?
I don't know what the fuck to tell. I
mean, I know you're outside, you know,
this is still basically human interaction.
So you're talking about feelings here.
So do you want to get childish
to say something mean to him?
Okay.
And uh,
I don't know.
You know what's weird is Josh just showed
up and now I have to smoke a cigar.
I have to read that shit. Yeah, dude,
don't fucking go back. Don't
go back for more. Right.
Or if you're going to go back for
more, um, sorry, I'm texting her. Hey,
hang on.
Yeah.
All right. Uh, yeah, you don't
need to put up with that shit.
Everything's like a pun in this.
Um,
the weird thing is that
you live with the guy.
It's never good to fuck your roommate.
You know,
it's debts that's never
going to be a good thing.
But I don't know how it works with
gay guys because you both guys, right?
So I would think you'd be able to just
be like, yeah, we're just fucking right.
Then we'll watch a game and fucking
drink some beers and I'll fucking piss in
your mouth. Evidently. I
guess that's how it goes down.
I don't know what the fuck
happens here. So I would just, uh,
if he sincerely is making you feel bad,
then I would,
I would try to find a better guy.
Um,
but considering you live with them, you
obviously get, you see consigned Kiki,
you can just blow the guy off. So at some
point he's going to be like, hey man,
you want to fuck? You got to be
like, Nah, I don't be like, why not?
It'd be okay cause you're a dick. You
say mean shit to me and I don't like it.
All right,
so why don't you in there and go rub one
out and piss in your own fucking mouth?
You fucking Dosha or you just move up.
All right,
that's a podcast. Everybody, God
bless each and every one of you.
Go fuck yourselves and I'll
check in on you on Thursday.